[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
after a slow start vaccinations are
speeding up across america
more than 56 million doses have been
administered so far
it's good news but we're still far from
the so-called herd immunity
but scientists say we need to be safe
our lead national correspondent david
begno is at uc davis medical center near
sacramento
david you spoke with a community that
has achieved that threshold
we sure did anthony look we were back
here in december initially when they got
the first vaccine and they were ready to
put it in the arms of their employees
and they called us about a week ago and
they said david we have achieved herd
immunity and here's how
when we were here in december they had
210 employees out sick due to covet you
know how many they had as of yesterday
only 10. more than 93 percent of the
employees here at uc davis health all
stepped up and said we will be
vaccinated
but the interesting part to this story
is that there were some who said no no
i don't want the vaccination and watch
what happened to one of them
meet chasity whitmer she's a nurse she
was delivering babies
at the height of the pandemic and when
her time came to be vaccinated
she hesitated what were some of your
initial concerns
um if i got the vaccine would i get
covered what would my side effects be
how long would it last good girl
but with a husband who stays home and
takes care of the kids
this is what changed her mind i was
orienting a relief charge nurse on my
unit
and we were kind of having a discussion
what happens if we got covered
we wouldn't be able to work we wouldn't
have income we wouldn't have health
insurance
and so we kind of just talked amongst
each other and
boosted our confidence up and stood in
line to get vaccinated
she and more than 90 percent of the
staff here at uc davis medical center in
sacramento california
have received at least one dose of the
vaccine
now listen to how high the rate is at
the emergency department
so we have a hundred percent compliance
amongst emergency physicians 100
100 amongst the emergency faculty this
is dr nathan cooperman
he is in charge of uc davis's emergency
department we were there back in
december when he got his first shot
how has vaccinating the vast majority
of employees here changed your ability
to staff the er
that is a great question so before the
vaccine came out
on any given day we would have between
100 150 employees
that were sick with covet and were
calling in sick and we're not coming
in now i think it's single digits i mean
there's less than 10.
suddenly there was like this pressure
lifted from our shoulders
it's not just uc davis health system
across the university of california
health system
cases among health staff dropped from
431 per week
to 171 per week and with fewer staff out
sick
the strain on health care workers has
really dropped too
ann tompkins the interim employee health
services director at uc davis medical
center showed us the data it's working
the numbers are a testament
people's stories are a testament that
the vaccine is truly working
and we're going to be okay back to nurse
whitmer for a moment
she's gone from being a vaccine skeptic
to an evangelizer
and here's why a few days after she
received her second dose
her husband her mother her three kids
and her grandmother all tested positive
for covet
you know who didn't she and her
grandfather and they are the only two in
the family
who have been vaccinated my husband was
extremely sick with coveted pneumonia
was here at the emergency department for
nine hours my grandmother spent 25 days
in the hospital with covid pneumonia and
is still recovering on oxygen
it's not fun seeing your family members
sick it's very
scary being a nurse watching them get
sicker and sicker and
whether to go to the hospital whether to
stay home what do i hear in your voice i
hear the breakup
yeah just reliving it
and when you relive it what makes you
emotional
um not knowing if my husband would be
one of the ones that would live or die
what a story she went from being an i
don't want it to uh
thank god i got it you know one health
official here at uc davis health said to
me yesterday david
covet 19 is no longer an occupational
hazard
within our health system think about
that for a minute back to you all you
always give us a lot to think about
david begna but what a story of chastity
whitmer story
it's almost a cautionary tale for people
that are sort of trying to decide what
to do how to do
yeah and you and the thing is when you
talk about her fear i mean
the statistics bear it out because
there's a statistic came out from the
federal government yesterday
life expectancy last year in the u.s
dropped by a full
year typically it moves by like weeks or
days
a full year among men and women among
black americans
it dropped by 2.6 years it's the biggest
drop since after world war ii
so it had an enormous impact on how long
people would be real but we all have to
get over that i think anthony i've heard
you say many times if they pulled it in
the garage
and he would roll up your scene any time
yeah to get it
you can use the same needle as anthony i
don't care wipe it off with a paper
towel
there is light at the end of the tunnel
david we thank you again